der tod sei eine ganz natürliche sache
das sagt der volksmund und die
religionen sagen uns der tod der gehört
eigentlich zum leben dazu was aber wenn
dieser tod und natürlich herbeigeführt
worden ist zb durch einen mord wir
wollen sprechen über den tod die mörder
und die täter und das möchte ich gerne
tun mit dem früheren chef der münchner
mordkommission josefus links götter
kunst
nach 42 jahren jetzt die pensionsgrenze
erreicht
das war der anstoß dafür macht ermittler
zu werden
das war von anfang an gar nicht mal so
klar ich habe ja bei der polizei ganz
normal
angefangen als streifenpolizist und
irgendwann wechselt man dann zur
kriminalpolizei so war es eben auch bei
mir und mord ermittler das ist natürlich
wie man so schön sagt die krönung das
ist das schwerste verbrechen das es gibt
es mord und deshalb ist natürlich
mordermittler die größte herausforderung
mir persönlich hat es zugesagt dass man
vorher nie weiß was auf einen zukommt
das war für mich der besondere reiz aber
diese vielen fälle von mord
selbst wenn sie sagen das ist sozusagen
die höchste stufe der polizeilichen
ermittlungen die spektakulärsten fälle
ist das eine sache mit der man sich
vorher schon mal auseinander gesetzt hat
haben sie irgendwann mal gesagt ich
möchte das nun mal als letzte stufe
meiner beruflichen tätigkeit machen es
war eine herausforderung aber das muss
man für sich herausfinden
das kann man vorher nicht wissen was auf
einen zukommt man weiß nicht ob man das
überhaupt verkraftet und es gab welche
die mussten wieder aufhören oder haben
wieder aufgehört weil sie das einfach
nicht geschafft haben
mit diesem thema umzugehen und da muss
man hineinwachsen und muss das für sich
herausfinden
so war es bei mir auch ich wusste ja
nicht was auf mich zukommt und ich hab
dann irgendwann festgestellt ich kann
damit umgehen
man muss die dinge annehmen man darf
sich nicht dagegen wehren man muss sich
diesen bildern stellen
man muss mit den angehörigen umgehen und
ganz schlicht und einfach viel darüber
reden aber wenn sie wenn sie mit diesen
bildern umgehen können handeln sie nicht
doch auch sehr bedrängt beschäftigt sie
können ja nicht an einen tatort
komm und zehn minuten später haben sie
alles vergessen
beschäftigen sie sich nicht mehr damit
verfolgen einen die bilder verfolgen ist
vielleicht ist ein bisschen ein
drastischer ausdruck aber es gibt bilder
die werde ich bis an mein lebensende mit
mir herumtragen sitzung war zum beispiel
hier der fall sedlmayr
das ist einer der fälle wo ich sagen
muss das war eine so schreckliche tat
und es war ein so schlimmer tatort diese
bilder brennen sich natürlich ein
oder wenn sie an kindstötungen denken
oder und kindsmord es gab also
verschiedene bilder die ich heute noch
vor augen habe detailliert vor augen
habe aber ich konnte mit umgehen wir
sind jetzt an dem grab von sedlmayr das
war ein prominenter schauspieler das war
ein ur bayer hat man gerne gesagt man
wusste von der von dem leben das er
sonst führte sehr wenig bis zu dem mord
was ist da passiert
das war wirklich einer der
spektakulärsten fälle die ich miterlebt
habe und wahrscheinlich nicht nur ich in
der kriminalgeschichte münchens wie sie
schon sagten ja war ja der parade bayer
er war ja der gestandene münchner und
die werbe ikone für bayerisches bier und
das schlimme war
so hatte ich den eindruck weniger die
tatsache dass ermordet wurde sondern
vielmehr die tatsache dass er schwul war
also diesen eindruck konnte man damals
gewinnen es war eine 1 1 ein sturm der
entrüstung der durch die bevölkerung
ging aber weniger wegen des mordes
sondern wegen aufgrund der tatsache dass
ich plötzlich herausstellte dass dieser
mann also dieses gestandenen mannsbild
homosexuell gewesen sein soll
im grunde genommen war da eine
bedauernswerte persönlichkeit weil er
ein doppelleben führen musste er hat die
wochenenden meistens sehr einsam
verbracht er hat strikt darauf geachtet
dass eine sexuelle veranlagung nicht
nach außen dringt er hat das alles total
abgeschirmt und hat dadurch natürlich in
gewisser weise ein sehr isoliertes leben
geführt wenn sie sich an diesem
konkreten fall noch erinnern wie es
damals die situation gewesen als sie zum
tatort gerufen wurden und wie war die
situation die sie dort vorfällen
vorfanden
das war ein tatort ich kam erst später
überhaupt an diesem tatort wo natürlich
kann man sich vorstellen das pure chaos
herrschte zunächst einmal das war
natürlich ein schock der durch die stadt
ging im wahrsten sinne des wortes er
wurde am sonntagabend aufgefunden
und so richtig realisiert wurde es
eigentlich erst dann im laufe des
montags und kann man sich natürlich
heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen die die
kadetten waren über monate hinweg voll
die auflagen sind 100 prozent gestiegen
das war also der spektakulärste mordfall
in der nachkriegsgeschichte
es war auch ihr spektakulärster mordfall
wobei man ja sagen muss im prinzip gehen
sie an diesem ort fälle immer mit der
gleichen art run mit der gleichen
ermittlung aber natürlich ist bei
prominenten die situation etwas anders
es war ein fall der superlative das kann
man wirklich sagen es gibt nichts was im
fall sedlmayr nicht eine rolle gespielt
hat im bereich der kriminaltechnik im
bereich der kriminalistik es wurde zum
ersten mal dna ausprobiert und soweit es
wurden v leute eingesetzt
das kann man sich heute kann immer so
vorstellen man ermittelt immer von innen
nach außen und in dem fall
er hatte ein gigantisches umfeld mussten
wir natürlich in alle richtungen
ermitteln
in erster linie natürlich auch in
richtung strich am ort wo mord wie man
damals sagte die waren ja damals leider
konnte sehr häufig und dann in anderen
anderer hinsicht natürlich auch in bezug
auf seine geschäftlichen hintergründe
auf seinen geschäftspartner auf die
finanziellen dinge auf das erbe und all
diese dinge die mit seinem privatleben
zu tun hatten und in bilderreihe
natürlich auch mit gewissen
verstrickungen im antiquitätenhandel er
hatte ja da eine bereits eine
vorgeschichte in der beziehung denken
sie an die blutend bürger madonna er war
ja in dem bereich auch ziemlich
verhaftet es gab also eine ganze menge
an ermittlungs richtungen die alle
bedient werden mussten und deshalb auch
eine große sonderkommission die jetzt
diesen fall zu behaupten wie geht ein
mord ermittler wie gingen sie auch als
chef der macht ermittlung in einem
solchen fall oder in einem anderen
mordfall vor was macht man zunächst wie
untersucht man einen solchen fall
zunächst einmal haben wir den tatort das
ist unser erster anlaufpunkt wir
ermitteln ja immer zurück in die
vergangenheit wir beginnen bei der
stunde null kommen und den tatort dort
findet man die leiche und dann ermitteln
wir zurück in die vergangenheit
wer war diese person welches umfeld
hatte sie was gab es in der
vergangenheit
und dann steht die ermittlung auf zwei
säulen
das eine sind die sachbeweise und das
andere sind die personen beweise dass
hand unsere zwei ermittlungsrichter also
der erkennungsdienst arbeitet akribisch
am tatort und sucht nach spuren die in a
fingerabdrücke und alles andere und
gleichzeitig spielt natürlich die
vernehmung von personen die
entscheidende rolle
sie sind sehr bekannt gewesen deswegen
weil sie sehr spezialisiert waren sehr
erfolgreich war bei vernehmungen was ist
das 5 verhältnis bei einem verdächtigen
oder einem
bei denen sie sagen könnte was mit allen
mord zu tun haben man hat ja immer
menschen die man von anfang an
sympathisch findet oder besonders
unsympathisch findet sie mussten ja
eigentlich immer sehr neutral die sind
personen gegenüber sagen ja das ist
natürlich völlig unterschiedlich und 95
prozent aller gerichtsurteile beruhen
auf dem personen beweis
das heißt die vernehmung ist nach wie
vor unsere wichtigste informationsquelle
und viele bereiche
denken sie mal an alibi oder denken sie
an opfer bilder oder täterbilder kann
man eben nur durch
durch vernehmungen erarbeiten und das
ist schon richtig da gibt es natürlich
jetzt unterschiede es gibt taten oder
tatorte wo von vorne herein feststeht
wer der täter war
dann muss man eben überlegen welche art
von täter habe ich hier vor mir ist es
ein emotionaler hintergrund oder ist es
ein rationaler hintergrund der eiskalte
mörder zum beispiel ist anders zu
behandeln als jemand der aus eifersucht
oder aus rache tötet
das sind ebenso die verschiedenen
facetten und darauf muss man sich schon
einstellen
dann gibt es natürlich auch fälle bei
denen der tatverdacht nicht von haus aus
ersichtlich ist
den muss man erst erarbeiten da muss man
sich eben erst heranarbeiten und man
braucht auf alle fälle viele
erfahrungswerte man braucht ein breites
erfahrungswissen man muss wissen wie die
einzelnen täter ticken ein sexualmörder
ist anders als ein raubmörder oder ein
brutaler totschläger und das kann man
nur eine praxis lernen das heißt es ist
auch eine frage von großer erfahrung
dann hat man ja immer wieder vielleicht
auch in ihrer situation ein fall bei
denen dann ein verdächtiger oder jemand
der so quasi schon gesagt hat ich habe
damit zu tun
verhört wird und man könnte durch
druckmittel im zweifel sogar durch
folter ein leben retten wie sind sie da
versöhnlich mit
ich war gottseidank nie in dieser
situation ist es eine unmenschliche
situation wenn man sich das vorstellt
und in der regel ist es so dass man
natürlich bemüht ist dass das gegenüber
mit einem spricht wir sind natürlich
bestrebt das an der wahrheitsfindung
mitarbeitet wir sind auch daran
interessiert dass der täter ein
geständnis ablegt dass er die tat
einräumt dass er an der aufklärung mit
merkt aber da stößt man natürlich
logischerweise auch an seine grenzen
jeder mensch hat angst vor der strafe
jeder mensch will verbergen
jeder mensch erlebt ein täuschen das
verhalten an den tag und es gibt
situationen wo man dann wirklich
möglicherweise vor der frage steht
könnte jetzt noch ein menschenleben
gefährdet seien oder nicht
dieser mensch ihr weißes der könnte wenn
er wollte aber er will nicht und da kann
es schon dann zuspitzung gegeben und ich
kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass es da
auch als ultima ratio auch dazu kommen
kann dass man hier vielleicht bis ich
meinen sie meinen sicherlich diesen fall
in frage wenn man überhaupt keine andere
chance hat dann kann ich das
nachvollziehen wenn man sagt jetzt
probieren wir es noch mal in dem wir ihm
schmerzen andere und ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich genauso gemacht ich
glaube auch nicht dass es irgendeinen
menschen gibt es anders gemacht wie geht
man aber einen solchen fällen mit den
eigenen emotionen um
wir haben gerade gesagt dem zeugen oder
verdächtigen gegenüber müssen sie
möglichst neutral sein das ist völlig
klar aber man kann die persönlichen
emotionen nicht ausschließen
sie haben sicherlich auch fälle gehabt
von verdächtigen die ihm von anfang an
fest bei uns sympathisch waren wie kommt
man da gefühlsmäßig zurecht man muss
seine emotionen beherrschen
man muss sie im griff haben die hat man
natürlich aber man muss auch einen
kinder gegen mörder gegenüber neutral
bleiben
sonst ist man für diese tätigkeit aber
wie schaffen sie das
der fall des achtjährigen jungen der
getötet worden ist das schafft man in
der form dass man ja den den
aufklärungserfolg will
und dann nimmt man das in kauf
an vorderster stelle stehen die
angehörigen
die wollen wissen was da geschah da
gerät man in eine bringschuld mann wie
den fall klären
man will diesen menschen helfen man will
auch dass der täter sagt was da passiert
ist
und da ist es schon dann sinnvoll wenn
man seine eigenen emotionen beherrscht
aber sie haben fälle gehabt in denen man
eigentlich gesagt hat das hätte nicht
passieren müssen
wenn zum beispiel jemand in haft
geblieben wäre wenn er nicht eine
wiederholungstat eine neue tat hätte
durchführen können
wie stehen sie den angehörigen in einem
solchen fall gegenüber leite ich mit den
angehörigen und es gibt auch tatsächlich
sachverhalte und es gibt auch
tatsächlich fälle wo man allerdings
seinen zorn oder seine sein
unverständnis nicht gegen die gegen
irgendwelche beteiligte richten kann
sondern das leben an der gesetzlichen
lage und natürlich kann man das nicht
verstehen wenn man einen kindermörder
vor sich hat und dann erfährt dass er
schon einmal ein kind getötet hat und
dass man ihn freilassen musste obwohl
bekannt war dass er wieder töten würde
das übersteigt einfach das verständnis
eines normal denkenden menschen und das
kann man natürlich nicht nachvollziehen
aber wird man da auch nach so vielen
jahren und so fielen
sie bearbeitet haben selber sehr radikal
wird man da sehr viel härter also ich
glaube ich schon dass eine der beruf
verändert wo das man in gewisser weise
auch die dinge realistischer sieht ich
glaube auch dass man durch so einen
beruf in der richtung verändert wird
dass man einfach realist wird vom
idealisten zum realisten wenn man ideale
hatte
man sieht die dinge nicht mehr so sehr
durch die rosarote brille und man kommt
vielleicht auch von gutmenschen etwas
weg sondern man sieht die dinge halt so
wie sie sind und wenn man will kann es
auch sein dass man sagt man wird zum
sogenannten hardliner zum zyniker nein
zum zyniker bin ich glaube ich nicht
geworden und wird man auch nicht
es gibt immer noch mehr gute und
anständige menschen als böse menschen
ich habe auch den glauben an die
menschheit nicht verloren man darf nicht
vergessen es ist ja nur ein kleiner teil
der zum bösesten des bösen neigt aber
man muss natürlich schon darauf achten
dass das nicht über bord und man ist
schon verpflichtet dass man jeden
einzelnen fall aufklärt das recht an die
angehörigen aber zum zyniker bin ich
nicht geworden aber zum hardliner schon
das hier war ein lieblingslokal von
moshammer hier sind wir in grünwald in
einem prominenten vor ort einem sehr
teuren vorort von münchen
was macht denn fälle von prominenten bei
ihnen aus man hat so den eindruck da
schaut die öffentlichkeit besonders
drauf ist auch der druck so etwas
herauszubekommen was sind die umstände
gewesen wer ist der täter
besonders groß gewesen für sie doch das
kann man schon so sagen das ist
natürlich für nicht klar dass das
interesse der öffentlichkeit und der
medien druck gigantisch ist wenn es
einen prominenten trifft oder wenn ein
prominenter beteiligt war
das liegt in der natur der sache und so
war es natürlich auch ebenfalls der herr
moshammer hier tot aufgefunden wurde
waren wir schon dutzende von
fernsehteams bevor ich überhaupt am
tatort war also die fernsehteams waren
vor der mordkommission da also auf jeden
fall vor mir also bis ich hierher kam
war schon der gesamte bereich hier mit
medien und mit kameras und reportern
voll und da kann man schon sehen oder
man konnte schon ahnen was das für einen
auftrieb werden wird und dahin steht
sicherlich auch eindruck auch für die
ermittler natürlich ein öffentlicher
druck ein medien druck aber ich muss
gleich vorhersagen für uns macht das
keinen unterschied also der aufwand
ermittlungs technisch ist nicht größer
wenn es einen prominenten betrifft also
bei einem obdachlosen
aber wie war das denn in dem konkreten
fall von moshammer in dem konkreten fall
war es zb so dass durch diese dna spur
die wir hier fanden eine
gesetzesänderung stattgefunden hat
vorher vor moshammer konnten wir zum
beispiel tatortspuren nur dann
analysieren lassen wenn ein
richterlicher beschluss vorlag
nach mühsamer war das auch ohne
richterlichen beschluss möglich und
dadurch natürlich wesentlich schneller
und auch der katalog in welchen fällen
man eine dna analyse erstellen lassen
darf wurde erweitert also es hatte eine
gesetzesänderung zur folge und ich
glaube nicht dass das bei einem fall
auch geschehen wäre der jetzt unter der
rubrik alltags fall passiert wäre also
das kann man ja fast als prinzip dann
annehmen der fall eines prominenten kann
zu einer gesetzesänderung führen wäre
das in einem fall eines normalen mordes
in anführungsstrichen auch passiert es
ist schon immer davon abhängig wie groß
die öffentliche resonanz ist
ich habe auch bei einem mord an einem
achtjährigen jungen miterlebt dass es
gott sei dank zu einer gesetzesänderung
kam und zwar zur nachträglichen
sicherungsverwahrung auch bei
jugendlichen auch bei tätern die nach
jugendrecht verurteilt wurden
sie haben gerade von den dna-spuren
gesprochen sie haben über viele
jahrzehnte ja auch dann die technische
entwicklung mit bekommen also die
aufnahme von spuren das analysieren von
spuren was ist da in den letzten
jahrzehnten passiert
es ist eine wahre revolution was mit
dieser technik mit dieser neuen
errungenschaft dna geschehen ist wie
sich das fortentwickelt hat das war
fantastisch festzustellen dass begann ja
etwa ende der 90er jahre damals brauchte
man noch ganze bündel von haaren oder
größere mengen blut damit man eine
dna-spur analysieren konnte sedlmair war
der erste fall bei dem man es versucht
hat anhand von zigarettenkippen dass es
damals noch gescheitert das war 1990 und
erst 1999 2000 und den dreh herum haben
sich die methoden immer mehr verfeinert
und heute genügt eine winzige
hautschuppen
das hat dazu geführt dass sehr viele
tötungsdelikte nachträglich aufgeklärt
werden konnten
bundesweit sind es bis heute weit über
300 die nachträge ich aufgeklärt werden
konnten was wiederum dazu geführt hat
dass die zahl der tötungsdelikte stark
zurückgegangen ist
ich bin überzeugt das hängt auch damit
zusammen mit dieser aufklärung der
sogenannten altfälle oder wie man es im
fernsehen and cold cases und täter
berechnen ja ihr risiko und ich bin
überzeugt dass es einer der gründe warum
hier die tötungsdelikte so stark
zurückgegangen man hat ja viele
diskussionen darüber immer wieder wenn
es zum beispiel immer telefonüberwachung
geht wenn es darum geht wanzen
anzubringen wenn man jemanden
verdächtigt sie sind ein ermittler
gewesen
das heißt sie müssen daran interessiert
gewesen sein möglichst viel technik
einzusetzen möglichst nahe an
verdächtige raten zu kommen gibt es für
sie aber auch einen punkt wo sie sagen
jetzt ist da eine privatsphäre in die
ich nicht mehr rein darf ja die gibt es
für mich auch ich bin ein
leidenschaftlicher verfechter unseres
rechtsstaates und es muss
selbstverständlich grenzen gehen
natürlich als ermittler hat man den
auftrag straftaten in beziehungsweise
schwere verbrechen aufzuklären und da
hängt es eben daran davon ab welche
möglichkeiten uns der gesetzgeber an die
hand gibt
sie haben in der zeit ihrer tätigkeit
als ermittler und als chef der
mordkommission sicherlich den ein oder
anderen fall wie sieht ein neuer
moshammer also prominente mordopfer
gelöst aber sie hatten auch diejenigen
von denen man nicht sehr viel liest und
sie hatten vor allen dingen auch fälle
mit denen sie sich auch selber sehr
stark auseinander gesetzt haben die sie
sehr stark beschäftigt habe bei 1 wochen
besprechen wir befinden uns jetzt in
einem waldstück nordwestlich von münchen
einflugschneise des flughafens heute
hier hat sich was zu getrag was auch für
sie persönlich sehr schwer zu verkraften
war ja das war in der tat eine der
brutalsten mordfälle
ich glaube in der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte hier in dem
waldstück wurden zwei menschen in einer
nacht bei lebendigem leibe enthauptet
und zwar von einem polizeibeamten und
das kann kollege verloren und das war
ein kollege der münchner polizei und das
motiv war pure habgier hat der
polizeibeamte hatte eine ex-freundin und
diese ex-freundin hat eine erbschaft
gemacht hat so 140000 euro geerbt also
geld von dem niemand etwas wusste
und das hat seine gier erweckt und nach
einem schweren inneren kampf so wie er
geschildert hat hat er sich entschlossen
sie zu töten
und dieses geld an sich zu bringen und
weil dann auch noch deren aktueller
freund informiert war über ein treffen
zwischen den beiden
er musste er auch den töten und ob man
es glauben will oder nicht
er hat dann diese junge frau zu einem
treffen gelockt hat sie dann betäubt mit
einem mix aus kakao und rohypnol hat sie
dann hierher geschafft in dieses
unwegsame waldgebiete und hat sie hier
mit einer axt enthauptet dann ist er zum
freund gefahren hat den freund heraus
geklärt unter einem vorwand hat ein
unfall vorgetäuscht
der fuhr natürlich mit auch den hat er
dann betäubt und hat ihnen an der
gleichen stelle ebenfalls enthauptete
leiche es hier gefunden und von einem
bären sammler
die leiche hatte ins unterholz gezogen
und hat sie dort vorläufig versteckt und
die köpfe und die hände die rub getrennt
hat hat er in einem feld vergraben und
erst wochen später wurde dann von einem
bären sammler starker verwesungsgeruch
wahrgenommen in diesem waldgebiet
und hat dann den zuständigen fast
aufseher verständigt und der fand dann
schließlich hier im dichten unterholz
diese beiden torschuss wie ist das
aufgeklärt worden
die ermittlungen haben ja schon lange
vorher begonnen
das ganze begann mit einer
vermisstenanzeige die beiden jungen
menschen waren vermisst worden und im
rahmen der ermittlungen zu dieser
vermischung stieß man auf einige
ungereimtheiten in der wohnung der
jungen frau beispielsweise oder an ihrem
fahrzeug das im keller stand und dann in
an dem grasbüschel undsoweiter hingen
und an den blutspuren entdeckt wurden
kamen dann dahinter dass das wohl ein
verbrechen gewesen sein dürfte was hier
zugrunde lag
und in dem zusammenhang wiederum wurde
natürlich überprüft wer waren die
personen mit denen sie zuletzt kontakt
hatte und so schließt man auch auf
diesen ex-freund der polizeibeamte war
in münchen und hat auch ihn befragt
anfänglich hat er natürlich jeden
kontakt abgestritten
dann aber hat sich das doch durch
zeugenaussagen verfestigt dass er wohl
doch derjenige war der das opfer zuletzt
gesehen hat und so hat sich der
tatverdacht gegen ihn immer mehr
erhärtet
was haben sie selber damals so besonders
schwer empfunden für sie persönlich dass
es jemand war der polizist war oder dass
sie ihn kannten was hat den für sie so
furchtbar entstehen lassen
also für mich war schon furchtbar dass
es ein polizeibeamter war
man sagt zwar immer die polizei ist ein
spiegelbild der gesellschaft
ich habe da eine etwas altmodische
einstellung für mich ist ein
polizeibeamter ein mensch der für gesetz
und ordnung steht und das hab ich schon
als besonders traurig empfunden dass ein
polizeibeamter zu einer so schrecklichen
tat fähig ist der vorher noch seinen
dienst versehen hat der als guter
polizist galt der sich nichts
schulden kommen hat lassen der sogar
vorbildlich war und für höhere
laufbahnen vorgesehen war und dass
dieser mensch dann eine so schreckliche
tat begangen hat so kaltblütig
das war für mich unfassbar das ist ja
auch so wie sie es beschrieben haben
eine unglaublich brutale tat gewesen im
gesetz ist einer der der grausamsten
taten gewesen die ich erlebt habe
wie stehen so einer grausamkeit
gegenüber das ist ja etwas raubtier haft
es im menschen sagen manche psychologen
manche pädagogen wie stehen sie so anna
im normalen menschlichen leben kaum
vorstellbaren brutalität gegenüber das
kann man nur durch professionelle
distanz ertragen
man versucht ja immer irgendwie
nachzuvollziehen ob dieses tatmotiv noch
begreifbar ist oder nicht
bei vielen tötungsdelikten ist es
begreifbar zumindest kann man mit dem
verstand erfassen warum jemand das getan
hat denken sie mal an häusliche gewalt
oder an annan täter die vorher opfer
waren
das ist ja irgendwo noch verständlich
aber in diesem fall war das überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehbar das war mit dem
normalen verstand überhaupt nicht
fassbar dass jemand wegen lumpige 140000
euro
zwei menschen bei lebendigem leibe in
einer nacht tötet und dann hinterher zum
betriebsausflug mit pferd als sei gar
nichts gewesen
das hat uns gezeigt keiner trägt das
kainsmal auf der stirn und die
schrecklichsten morde
die werden nicht von der mafia begangen
oder von schrecklichen figuren wie
hannibal lecter oder solchen film
figuren sondern die kommen tatsächlich
im ganz normalen leben vor
haben sie den eindruck dass jeder mensch
ein mörder sein könnte
davon bin ich fest überzeugt ich habe
nichts anderes erfahren
90 prozent der mörderinnen und mörder
wobei es wesentlich mehrere mörder waren
hatten keine prekäre kindheit hatten
keine gewalterfahrungen gemacht und
hatten ein bislang völlig um
schönes leben geführt und das wird
zwangsläufig zu dem schluss dass das
gute und das böse in uns allen
offensichtlich drin steckt und wir haben
den freien willen uns zu entscheiden
und das ist nicht abhängig immer von
kriminellen energie ab von kindesbeinen
an sondern dass es abhängig von ganz
bestimmten ereignissen und entwicklungen
die im leben eintreten können und die
aus einem menschen einen mörder machen
können
haben sie den eindruck dass die
perspektive zu sehr auf die täter
gerichtet wird und dass wir uns zu wenig
um die opfer kümmern
das ist der eindruck der entsteht aber
in einem strafverfahren stehen nun mal
die straftäter im mittelpunkt dass das
ist so das heißt ja auch strafrecht und
es geht natürlich in erster linie im
strafrecht um die täter und dadurch
entsteht auch der mittel der eindruck
dass die im mittelpunkt stehen
aber es ist tatsächlich so dass
natürlich die opfer immer ins
hintertreffen geraten was sehr schade
ist und was einem auch unverständlich
vorkommt und da es glaube ich auch noch
ein großer nachholbedarf besonders weil
er die rechte der beschuldigten wenn man
das verfolgt immer mehr ausgeweitet
werden
die beschuldigten werden mehr oder
weniger immer stärker hofiert immer
steiger umsorgt und die opfer treten
dadurch immer mehr in den hintergrund
sie haben also ganz oft wenn ich das
richtig verstehe den eindruck dass das
was dort an tat geschehen ist nicht
wirklich im rechtssystem entsprechend
geahndet wird dass die
verhältnismäßigkeit nicht mehr stimmt
ich habe den eindruck dass man oft nicht
die realität zu recht nachvollziehen
kann wenn dann ein jahr später oder
monate später dann die
gerichtsverhandlung stattfindet das ist
nur eine imaginäre wirklichkeit und da
hat man schon den eindruck dass völlig
vergessen wird was die menschen denen
das angetan wurde
was sie durchlitten haben und wenn man
natürlich auch bedenkt dass allzu milde
urteile oder ein allzu großzügig es
umgehen mit dem täter
was das für die opfer bedeutet das
erlebt man natürlich nur in der praxis
das erlebt man nicht vor gericht sondern
das erleben in erster linie wir
ermittler weil wir den engsten kontakt
haben
zu den opfern wie es in der die ersten
amtspersonen die mit diesen menschen
zusammentreffen
und von daher weiß man dass es noch mal
eine zusätzliche demütigung sein kann
wenn die täter dann mit einer relativ
milden strafe davonkommen
das ist die realität und so ist es und
das kann ich auch nachvollziehen sind
religiös erzogen worden
können sie mit der religion noch am
anfang ich muss ehrlich sagen die
zweifel ob es einen gott gibt es sind
bei mir immer stärker geworden im laufe
der jahre
weil ich doch immer wieder vor
situationen stand wo ich mich gefragt
habe
wenn es einen gott gibt einen
barmherzigen gott warum lässt dass so
etwas zu und darauf habe ich noch keine
antwort gefunden
aber wenn ich ihm begegnet dann frage
ich ihn mal aber dann müssen sie sich
nach all dem doch wünschen dass es
irgendwo eine ausgleichende
gerechtigkeit mit das würde ich mir sehr
wünschen und das hoffe ich auch dass das
der fall
das ist irgendwo eine ausgleichende
gerechtigkeit gibt und wenn es die gibt
dann sollte genauso aussehen wie sich
die menschen erdacht haben nämlich eine
helle für die ganz bösen ein paar ein
fegefeuer für die weniger schlimmen und
ein paradies für solche wie sie und mich
dankeschön